how's it going bros my name is today I'm
very excited cuz we're playing The
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt this game looks
awesome I'm very excited to check it out
with you bros some of that residue
alright so just a story story and sword
blood and broken bows def march you were
truly insane and loving it well that's
me alright let's go
[Music]
that guy's pissed Jesus Christ for
horsey why
oh he's pissed I'd be pissed too
[Music]
Oh God what the [ __ ] is this
I hate when that happens to me he knows
everything
[ __ ] crow [ __ ]
Oh shame
[Music]
you missed
oh [ __ ]
talk about being in the wrong place at
the wrong time don't kill it on the
horse please [ __ ] sake
thank you
[ __ ] looks beautiful and she
[Music]
that
I didn't
all right of course
the crowd scale thing of cards are they
gonna find that now I don't know no no
no no no wait let me go back there we
are
oh yeah
now that's what I'm talking about
thank you camera angles oh yes I know I
picked a good game yes now that's what
I'm talking about
and never so casual about it you know I
don't find that amusing I think we both
know he likes it
oh hell no all right Iran Iran Iraq it
wasn't meant right hurry
it's midday you promised the Siri you
train with her go before best Amir bores
her to death with those etchings oh [ __ ]
the crawfish [ __ ] him up in it that
[ __ ]
[Music]
so later then hmm
see you later let's see you later right
am i right am i right am i oh
I'll skip this think I'm stupid
it's the only action I've ever gotten
nice camera work this game this game
knows how to work
oh okay yes dad Buddha inside tasteful
sideboob quality 100% best game ever so
far oh cool also she's the girl in the
cutscene
I thought in fact we were looking for
here
[Music]
all right so here we are in the world of
The Witcher I can I can walk around I
can jump that's always good I can climb
over buckets course a girl
I want to say hi to her signor I hear
her there she is hey girl what's up girl
you walk play game hey hey pay attention
to me please I love you I can talk to
her see I thought Siri can stand to wait
a little longer
it's uninstructed come on go not to
mention unreasonable I want to stay with
you a little longer I missed you a lot
and I missed used but we have plenty of
time to make up for it now go and train
with her
it'll give me a chance to put my face on
all the women I've known you're the only
one who does that before what's it
matter
oh I ship them so much already
no but seriously we need it yes damn it
yes damn it isn't this yes there is
something I want to do damn it oh god
don't punch her please some puncher come
on girl I'm right here alright maybe I
should actually play the game I'm sorry
alright let's take a look outside
I bet it's very nice I guess I'll go
back to me and crawfish hashtag paved
fish No oh [ __ ] I can pinch it that's
awesome well let's check out here
oh my freaking gown at its buted
mountain pass as beautiful as ever
mm all right use the Witcher senses to
find the key to the bedroom door all
right Witcher senses go oh look it's
right here how about that you think I
didn't need magic to find that [ __ ] all
right let's go down I'll see you later
crawfish I love you I miss I miss her
already she was my best friend and my
lover here we go
[Music]
old witches fast asleep series
disappeared somewhere of course nice
starts bro what's your band name
[Music]
guess she prefers practice to theory hmm
why she's badass time to wake up master
these lessons so boring they put you to
sleep too damn it but are taking notes
on ghouls and al Ghul's wanted to rest
my eyes making her slow through that
brick no wonder she took off John of
Bruce lacks Flair true but he's reliable
not like a hogwash they print nowadays
she's tackling the pendulums right how
many times do I have to tell her don't
train alone it only embeds your errors
bring her young damsel to the lower
courtyard she wants to practice she'll
get to practice don't get mad at her
because I'm kidding had it or had the
same hair the hell not the
whippersnapper refuses to do as she's
told you like that about her
fine I suppose I'm partly to blame but
this has to end now
killing monsters is not something to be
taken lightly Siri must understand that
if she is to become one of us
I'll see you below Oh oh it's that way
isn't it I bet he was the crowd fish
nice boots
[ __ ] Prada boots and [ __ ] what can I
get them wrong how's that wrong now I
see why you were so eager to practice
strike awesome what's wrong foot work
get down what do you what do you think
of course we do flips kind of game you
think this is all right take off the
blindfold
you got work to do
your reflexes are still slow maybe for a
Witcher think drowners or Stricker's
we'll go easy on you because you haven't
undergone the mutations knowing your
shoes I'd fear vesemir more than a nice
trigger disobeying his instructions
unwise yes I know and you know that's no
excuse I'm sorry won't happen again
as bad a night better not Beza Maher
said if it does it'll make you eat a
bowl of slugs covered in salt yeah
exactly well that's the cutest thing it
is Dave come on we'll practice with the
others down below shall we run the walls
of course yeah of course there's a
Witcher school or an elven bathhouse
maybe if you fall beat your bottom if
you know alright that's sorry okay if I
[ __ ] up now I'll look like an idiot I've
gotta make this right hundred percent
there we go
I know how to play games I do this [ __ ]
all day son
okay I got a faster than her about
breathing through your mouth and rhythm
with your steps there it is ow I broke
my back Siri cut it out what is she
doing what am i doing
of course yes down here of course I
meant to do that
what nailed it
too slow girl win I win all right sure
go ahead and do that
am I going here yeah here the map tells
me
what the hell does that mean they're so
cute together same haircut and
everything Oh God not you guys [ __ ]
ugly anything to say for yourself young
lady
I'm very sorry uncle resume
Youngblood craves action I understand
that but when you fight a beast
knowledge counts as much as your silver
sword at the very least you want to be
able to tell a ghoul from an Algol by
markings like unto the panthera tigris
that enteric Aeneid dwells and by the
sickly paleness of its visit of course
hmm so you did read the chapter still
you should have asked if you were asleep
uncle vesemir yeah why don't you just
tell us so you did the reading why not
admit it right off
never counts on an advantage as soon as
it appears wait till it stands to have
maximum effect
uncle resumes words well looking rector
for a quick study quick
but mischievous fine we've talked enough
Geralt you're with me Lambert with Eskil
ciri with a dummy again stop groaning
and grab a sword
what do you think should we start by
reviewing the fundamentals or go right
to free training yeah let's do it should
work on the basics even skilled masters
need to hone the fundamentals and series
barely a novice now what that necklace I
bet I can 3d print it should do that
[ __ ] alright time for some action girl
sorry okay
draw your sword I know how to do that
there you go look I did it
aim at vesemir all right there you go
quick cuts three alright alright one two
three one two three well I put a slew
put slap on a slipper strike I'm
literally murdering him right now oh
there you go
can't touch this can't touch this you
too slow
in fact you're really bad actually I'm
sorry there you go roll out of the way
all right look miss me [ __ ] miss me
[ __ ] Oh shit's crazy calm down
huh repulsed straight counter-strike
I'll make your move sent how do I do it
come on then come on in bruh
there it is let's fight old man I got
you back son
what is she doing anyway oh gosh Oh
Harris to bring the data with clothes
we'll go over a few witches son I mean
let's start with wait by an image that
it is what does he want me to do Quinn
fairness okay Jerry
when is sometimes called the witches
shield now watch carefully to see why
awesome I want to see sparks pop a genie
IGN I play Mitch I'm sorry I'm so sorry
ser no this [ __ ] hard oh hey buddy come
on like a medieval Jedi ever say she
influenced opponents minds there it is
sure you then love the Swedish names I'm
a brat Siri
all right slows him down hey come down
Crandall dampen the blow okay
I wasn't worried
I need this name habit highway throw the
bomb jump forward enough
you can't do that now
what am I doing wrong throw the bomb
breath air it Oh nailed it
100% so proud of me thank you I know
your parents who I do what I can
you're throwing these strobe on and
Trent yet nailed it I don't think I'd
actually do that it's okay one of these
days I'll do it now what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you it's over oh if I want to
I can joke eh no [ __ ] that Jesus calm
down
no how me why are they oh no other
people like this cancel find that helmet
Siri
I'll make sure to find every last blade
free oh it's just you and me now Demi I
love you tell me do you love me - I love
your beards what what how did you know I
love you because I love you YouTube
channel
alright let me look who you are then oh
god you're ugly
the hell is going on
that is one badass [ __ ] [ __ ]
I think I think it's a good guy Jesus
Christ
alright it looks like when I hear that
there but hope you guys enjoyed this
episode live like we did and if you want
more let me know I'll see you in the
next one as always Barb's Royal Griffin
beat tips worn gray hairs in the coat